what do you think the biggest mistake is
people make when they're pitching at vc
you know raising capital is a full-time
job and when you have to also run a
business
it makes it a lot more difficult
today's episode of model monsters is
brought to you by
tubebuddy
tubebuddy is your best friend on your
road to youtube success
i use it every day on my channel to get
more views and subscribers
automate the boring tasks and split test
my thumbnails and titles
i've done over 3 800 split tests which
have led to results like taking this
5 year old video that was getting 250
views a day
and just by changing the thumbnail it
blew up to 15
000 views per day you can get started on
tubebuddy for
free at tubebuddy.com evan
hey i'm alex how are you good how are
you
good thanks thanks for taking the time
to talk with me today so if you guys
don't know this is alex he's from a
company called
ago partners that he founded or
co-founded
uh that's a venture capital firm looking
to
it's like the venture capital firm with
a heart
i don't know how else you would describe
it but basically trying to try to invest
in companies who aren't just
trying to make a buck obviously that's
important but um trying to make the
world a better place
uh and yeah personally invested over 60
million dollars in different businesses
and i thought i'd pick your brain today
on kind of
what it takes for entrepreneurs to raise
money from a bc because a lot of people
are they feel like they've got a great
idea they feel like they
you know want to make the world a better
place but they don't have the resources
the team the capital to do it just as a
starting point what advice you give to
somebody who
feels like they've got that great idea
but not the money to do it
i mean honestly it's about dedication to
what you're doing your mission
there's a lot of founders that we've met
with over the years that haven't had the
same passion
um and then the companies that we ended
up investing in were with founders that
were obsessive
that wanted to make this work we're
going to put everything in their heart
to make sure
that they would accomplish their mission
statement and i think
that there are a lot of founders out
there that yeah sure they're obsessive
with their business but they don't
take everything that they can do to make
sure that they win
and there's a lot of tough times i mean
it's very hard raising capital even on
from the venture standpoint like it's
never easy to raise a fund
and especially when you start out early
in your career you don't have a track
record either
building a company or building a fund
and raising capital and making good
investments
that it's really hard out there so it's
really about
kind of the obsessiveness of your idea
and what you're wanting to accomplish i
think that's the thing that always kind
of sparks me
when i look at a company and a founder
is like how much do you want this
like you're not going to let anything
stop you and our best investments have
been with founders that have been
obsessive in that way
i love it what do you think the biggest
mistake is people make when they're
pitching at vc
arrogance okay um so
silicon valley a lot of the companies
now have been you know they've been able
to raise a lot of capital quite easily
and they tend to
kind of overvalue themselves and i think
you never know what's going to happen in
the world and i think
kovid's a perfect example of something
that no one saw really coming
and some companies weren't prepared to
weather that storm and if you were
priced too high and you had to
do a down round or you just didn't have
the right capital structure set up
you could get pretty beat up i mean
we're lucky that cobit was such a short
sort of effect in the terms of in
finance but
you know who knows what's going to
happen down the road so i think that's
where you really have to be prepared for
what's going to happen down the road and
if it's raising capital b be open-minded
to different prices different valuations
different types of investors and not
just be focused at one thing
right well and feedback too right i mean
yeah i'm sure you like actually not you
want you don't want to run the company
but you want to
invest in somebody who will listen to
your perspective on what
changes they might need to make of
course i mean that takes some leadership
um
from the vc itself but also you want the
founder to have his path and really know
what he wants to create
and you can be there to support if it's
you know making introductions
to other vc funds or you know spending a
lot of time with them and trying to try
to help them figure out what path and
how
to get liquidity down the road but you
know again the best companies we've
invested in the founders had
knew what they needed to do to be
successful um we were just able to help
them with capital and help them guide
them along
but we were able to pick some some
really good winners and from the
leadership of the team
um in those companies how often do you
have to replace the founder
where where like they stay in the
business it's just ceo
isn't the right role for them it happens
especially as companies grow and scale
at
you know to a very very high level and
end up going public you know some ceos
aren't meant to be public ceos
and a lot of the founders recognize that
and they kind of take themselves out of
the business at a certain point so it's
it's it really is dependent on the
founders i mean if you look there's a
lot of companies that are still
that are publicly traded today that were
venture backed and the ceo is still
there
and he's been able to execute on a high
level i think it just it really depends
on each founder
um i have been around so many different
ones that it's hard to have any sort of
like across the line
um story for that but i think most ceos
of
you know from venture companies are
open-minded to being pulled out i mean i
think most of them
want to stay there but i think they want
the best for the business
and whatever takes that path is is the
most important
well and also i guess the awareness to
say hey maybe
i shouldn't be the person running this
that that's something that's i mean i
used to be in the bc world
way back um and that was something that
was a a challenge sometimes
like hey you you could be a great cto
but you
don't have the leadership skills to
actually take this
to where it needs to go and just kind of
humble pie
uh because they might have built this
thing for three years and yeah it's
their baby and they don't want to give
it up to somebody else
yeah but it's really about leadership
right for me is like to see if you're a
great ceo you can build a team around
you it's not just your show it's the
ability to be able to hire people bring
in the right team
and create an environment that people
want to work at and want to succeed at
and you know some ceos can do that with
a small team but as the business scales
suddenly they have a lot more difficulty
being able to kind of rein in the team
and make sure everyone's productive and
i
think that age used to be a thing that's
very different now
um a lot of these companies had very
young ceos and would go out to meet
investors and people would look at them
like oh
you know you're like 22 years old what
do you know but i think that landscape
has changed drastically um
over the last decade i mean since i
started i started my fun when i was 22
i'm 32 now
and it's a very different world out
there i mean most of the people i'm
meeting with founders are younger than
me
yeah how is that for you being
a 22 year old saying i'm going to start
a fund
well i got lucky my business partner um
joe sandberg
came from like a deep financial
background he was at blackstone and
tiger global
so he brought a lot of legitimate
legitimacy to me early on in my career
which is very important i mean you can't
just like wake up one morning and decide
you want to invest i mean even if you
have
unlimited capital at your disposal
people still will want partnerships with
people that actually know what they're
doing
and have the ability to help scale your
business
so yeah i mean definitely at the
beginning i used to get like people look
at me
who are you like what do you think
you're doing and i was like well you
know this is the way it is i want to
build something um
and i'd love to be involved in your
business and people took bets on me
early on in my career i mean my biggest
investors took big bets on me
um and they continue to do so
so what are some of the criteria you
look at you're going to invest into a
company
uh the financial requirements as well as
you said the personality traits of just
like being dedicated yes yeah
so for the financial requirements and
also what does it mean to
to do good for the world to qualify to
get in
uh i mean it really depends what stage
we're investing at you know in a seat or
series a stage like we did in our first
few funds
you're really betting on the person and
the idea i mean i think addressable
market size
was a big thing for us early on like can
this business serve a massive market
um but as you get in later stages yeah
obviously financials get into the
picture
um we think we like to focus more on
profitability
a lot of venture funds don't really care
about profitability um they just care
about growth
and we want to invest in companies that
have a path to profitability and not
just be like oh we're going to grow for
10 years and
we'll figure it out at some point um we
really care about that
so how quick how quick do they have to
start making money profits
i mean again it depends so much on the
business but you know i'd like to see it
in the first couple years at least that
they have a clear path outside of spend
on marketing
because if you take marketing out you
know companies can be profitable a lot
faster but
you got to ramp up and you know people
want to see results
are you taking people with a concept
or are you taking people who've already
gotten some angel funding and took a
certain level where are you coming in
i mean we've done both i mean our
biggest investment is this
um neo bank called aspiration which is a
social mission driven online bank
and you know we've grown the business
from day one it started out
out of our office in la and now they
have 200 employees you know their
standalone business they've raised a
couple hundred million dollars of
venture capital money so
in that case we helped that from day one
in other cases you know we were
a lot more passive and weren't as
involved and kind of just
thought that it was a good idea like the
founder and then back them
yeah and then other and other companies
we've really taken a deep dive
i saw that on the website and i was
curious what what would you call a neo
bank
it's an online bank i mean it's it's so
there's the banking space has kind of
changed over the last
five four or five years you have
companies like chime you have companies
like aspiration
that were originally marketing layers on
top of existing banking structure
so they don't actually own their debits
they don't actually own the accounts
it's more of just a layer on top where
they get debit card fees and
and different ways to capitalize on that
but it's more of like how
how big of a business can you get this
to where aspiration they actually own
their whole entire core so they own the
customers
their cash management account which is
similar to merrill lynch
they're not a fully licensed bank
because that limits growth and the
business still wants to grow
quickly and that's where the value is i
think long term
but these online banks are really
kind of the future and i think people
will decide which bank they want to go
to to match
what their value proposition is you know
some people want the highest interest
rate possible
others care about planning trees like
what we offer on our debit card
um and trying to match their actual
social values with their money
and i think that i mean one of the more
interesting things that i found out
about banks were
when we started this business was you
have no idea where your money goes at
night
so these banks are lending your money to
you know fossil fuel companies gun
companies
private prison companies and most people
don't realize that and when you explain
to them that that's
the case people are sometimes horrified
and they're like whoa
how did this happen like i don't want to
i don't want to be involved in that
um and that's where aspiration comes in
um that we can give people that care
about that
a place to bank i love it so i've
actually got a banker on my wall
i've got that's that's ap giannini here
who started bank of italy which later
became bank of america
and and why he's my favorite
entrepreneur of all time and why because
he he lent he was the first bank to lend
money to immigrants
and he lent money based off a handshake
and a look in the eye
if you can imagine that for a bank and
judge the man by the calluses that he
had on his hands
um funded the golden gate bridge which i
know your your grandfather had a hand in
him my great grandfather yeah that's
what brought my family to the berry and
actually behind me
i have photos of the bridge nice
instructed
so so what would you say
like what's your message to
entrepreneurs who are trying to
trying to do good trying to make money
might be struggling trying to find their
path like what
is it encouragement is it is it they're
missing a skill set like what what do
you think most entrepreneurs need to
hear
that maybe they can qualify for vc but
most people won't so what what
what do you think is missing for most
entrepreneurs
i think some i mean from what i've seen
it's passion um
to really get to that point a lot of
people give up really early
um you know i've got i've gone through a
lot of stresses over the last few years
trying to build businesses
um it's great but it's also terrifying
at the same time and you're going to get
knocked down
at a certain point you got to believe in
what you're building like obsessively
maybe you're
the blind man on the block and you're
the only one that believes it but you
gotta really believe in what you're
doing and i think a lot of guys give up
early
or they just don't really they don't
they're not as committed to what they
want to accomplish
and if i looked at some of our best ceos
and some of our best founders i mean
they would literally
put their life on the line to keep the
business going i mean you know leverage
themselves put whatever they have to do
to make sure the business is successful
and you know that kind of persistence
and passion is something you want to
build
is key and so do you think people are
just chasing a trend
because i mean definitely at certain
points with like apps and all these
companies that have raised a lot of
venture
funding or haven't it's like everyone
and their mother tried to start a
company
after facebook which is great because
that creates a whole new market and you
know some ideas will work some ideas
won't
but that's not that's not sort of the
mission statement and founders that i
look for and i think it's really the
it's it's passion to building what they
care about
um and also i love what i do i mean you
must love what you do
so if you're a founder and you love the
business you're building i think you'll
be ultimately way more successful if you
don't really like it or don't really
understand what you're building it's a
lot harder
and so how do you suss that out because
that's kind of hard to see in a business
plan right is it is it going to dinners
with them like how do you try to assess
that out
i mean it's spending as much time with
them as possible um and i think you can
identify traits in people um
and when they're starting to build a
business very early on you can really
see them
and how they act how they pitch how they
talk about their business the way they
are around
other people employees in the business
even how they set up the capital
structure you know if there are three
partners
if it's an equal partnership or if one
owns more equity than the other
you know those are all things you look
for early on because you want to see how
these guys are going to work together
or how they'll be able to build
something
is there anything that you like they
have to do
like they have to go to dinner with you
or they have to go to a a dodgers game
or something like they have to do
something with you well i'm a driver
i'm a giants fan so let's go okay okay
you can't talk dodgers
forget those guys giants but you live in
l.a i do live in l.a okay
yeah okay but um no i was you know and
it
it's not really that i have to have a
meal with them or have to
you know go to dinner with them it's
more just like talking to them like this
like getting to understand what makes
them move
what makes them want to create um and
try to help them develop ideas and help
them you know keep their path
because it's hard to stay focused
there's a lot of distractions when
you're a young founder
you have to raise capital you have to
manage the business you have to hire
people
you know raising capital is a full-time
job and when you have to also run a
business
it makes it a lot more difficult so
that's where partnerships are really
important
um when i look at the best companies or
two or three founders or
and they could end up really helping
each other as the business scales
because one can focus more on capital
the other one can focus more on running
the business
it's hard to do two things at once is it
is it too soon like there's is there a
moment where it's too soon to raise
capital
where you tell companies like you got to
go back and get some more momentum and
actually build something
yeah i mean i think it depends what kind
of sector they're in like in the banking
space it's
it's very expensive to start a banking
platform right you can't just wake up
one morning and be like hey you have to
go through
you know the sec finra and all the
regulatory framework
but i mean if you start a great idea
tomorrow off of something that's easy to
build sure i mean
i've been pitched before and have
invested in something really early on
and other things take a long time
how much do you think geography plays
into it so like you want to invest in
la companies or california companies
versus new york or
or international i think it's changed a
lot i think
if you weren't in silicon valley it was
really hard to raise capital um i think
new york has become kind of a venture
hot spot so as los
angeles so is austin i mean and there's
a lot of founders now
that focus in certain areas to actually
get their funding like la companies are
like hey
you know we're going to become the next
big la business we want la investors
because we're going to help out the
community we're going to hire more
people we're going to build something
and i think that a lot of venture
capital firms in certain regions want to
back
companies that are based in their city
um and that's something that we
definitely look at too
like being based in la we want to see la
businesses be successful
and if we can help them from you know at
the beginning we're we're very
interested in that
so my audience is mostly american i'm
physically based here in toronto canada
okay and um like 20 of la's canadians
people kind of come down so if an
entrepreneur is looking at that
for the success of their business either
raising capital or finding partners or
just talent hub how much do you think
location actually plays into it
i mean it's pretty hard talent wise to
sometimes in certain areas to get them
to come down i mean
when aspiration was starting up it
wasn't the easiest thing to get
engineering talent because most of it
was in the bay area and they didn't want
to leave
you know their home if they had a family
there or just comfort of living
but it's really changed like la now has
has become a big hub
um for that i think thanks to snapchat
and some of the other big
tech companies that have been based in
la that have brought talent down
but yeah i know i think from a
talent-wise especially engineering
talent
they they can be very picky um about
where they want to go because there's
not
that many amazingly talented engineers
and they're very sought after
right i mean and and san francisco to
l.a at least is in the same state what
if
what if you're in like minnesota or
something i mean now with the world that
we live in with this and zoom you know
you can be anywhere
so i mean i think that's also going to
change a lot how people are
working for these tech companies because
you could work remotely
i mean facebook for example is like
doesn't even you don't have to go back
to the office if you don't want
to um and i think that that's going to
create
much more opportunity um for for people
in
in the venture landscape and
venture-backed businesses because you'll
be able to work anywhere
like i could be working with a french
company and talk to them you know every
day via this
and be in the same room just like i am
with my partner based on zoom
so i think that this whole culture
um through video chat and video
conferencing is only
going to become bigger and bigger i
think i mean
people are going to be very comfortable
doing this like i'm sitting at home
right now
and i can talk to you and i've got a
whole full day of meetings already
yeah i don't have to commute i don't
have to get in the car
do you think that changes the funding
landscape like would you
now more consider investing into a
minnesota company or a toronto company
or a london company
if it made sense or it's like no i still
want to be california uh no i mean i
think
we're very opportunistic i mean if
there's a great idea and there's a great
leadership team why wouldn't i invest
somewhere else
you know there's a company in istanbul
or a company in the philippines like
i'll go there
i love to travel i mean that's been for
me one of the hardest parts of covet is
the
the lack of travel because i was brought
up in switzerland my mom's french i
spent a lot of my life in africa growing
up so
i i miss that and i miss being able to
meet with people and shake someone's
hand and talk to them and look at them
in the eye and say hey
like are you really building this
business you know tell me about it
because
this is still great but it's not the
same i think the physical touch of
meeting somebody and
you know hearing them speak and how
their body language is is very different
especially when you're negotiating
i haven't negotiated yet over over zoom
so that'll be the
that'll be it's coming up soon i imagine
it'll be fine i'm
excited to see how that goes it's
interesting to see how many businesses
do make the shift and
who do go back to meeting in person
versus just
abandoning their offices yeah completely
la's been california's been a bit more
strict than other places
um during all this but you know in
europe pretty much everything's back on
i mean people are
meeting in person you know business
deals are happening
offices are opened la's still pretty
pretty shut down to a certain point
why was it so important to you to create
a fund
to do good you know i mean so many
people raise funds
and and entrepreneurs i think are going
to solve all the world's major problems
anyways yeah
and so it's part of what vc's do is
invest in entrepreneurs who go off and
change the world but
most vcs don't make that their core
tenant that
no this company has to do good why does
that mean so much to you
i mean i care deeply about values and i
also think that that's the biggest
opportunity
because in all the businesses that we've
invested in especially aspiration
to understand how much customers care
about their values
and not being able to find businesses
that match their values
so i think that if you can create that
you've created a niche for yourself and
it's still a very large market
um and i think that's what we see as the
future
as being able to match people with their
values match businesses with their
values match concepts of their values
and i think that the way when i look
forward five to ten years
i think that's only gonna become more
and more in picture
and in vogue because founders are gonna
understand that they're gonna need to
build businesses to match that
i mean already if you look just over the
last six months i mean
esg and social impact like those were
things those were tenants
in people's minds but in the last six
months there's been such a rapid move
towards that
and if you look at big firms like
blackrock starting an esg fund
or you know people caring about how
their employees and diversity
requirements like
that's only only going to get bigger and
bigger and
i think we were lucky that we saw it
kind of early on and we've been able to
back companies earlier on with those
vision and that and that sort of mindset
and i think that that'll give us a lot
of legitimacy moving forward and i think
that's something that
people that try to compete with us with
that will have a harder time because
it's
a maybe not as honest that they just
kind of jumped on the bandwagon
and that's the thing to show it it feels
like
a strategy as opposed to being
an actual core value let me know it's
still a core value
because it's something that we deeply
care about like not for you
you meant okay let's add this
environmental fund because that looks
sexy
and it's a good strategy but like at the
core we're still going to do all this
other stuff
100 and then like that'll just become
like a check mark
like do you offer esg sure we offer esg
um and you're already seeing that and
it's only gonna get bigger and bigger
and companies are gonna have to
get into it otherwise they're gonna be
left behind but it's hard for big big
behemoth companies especially if you
take the big banks
like they can't stop lending to fossil
fuels i mean they can't
they can't stop overdraft fees they
can't stop
certain things like that because it
would completely affect their business
in the long term
so that's where i think you can find
companies that kind of are the in
between
that can really create that and create
those businesses and either will get
acquired
down the road or hopefully standalone
companies that can go public and really
revolutionize an industry
is there name for those companies like
if it's guns or oil like
is there a category that they can be
lumped into you
also like the the sort of the bad
companies people yeah exactly what is
your name for them
not really i mean it's just more of like
you know
what you care about like because people
have different values you know some
people might value certain things versus
others and that's why there's going to
be a lot of businesses that are going to
be out there to create different things
do you know what percent like bank of
america's business might be tied to
that kind of stuff i don't have those
numbers in front of me but it's probably
pretty substantial
significant okay cool so i know i know
we're kind of
you know getting close to the end uh a
bunch of people are going to see this
that haven't heard of you before
what's the thing that you're working on
now to make you want to come
more public and start spreading the
message honestly
it's just about like building great
businesses and being around great
founders i think that
we want to build companies that create
that positive impact and we've done that
with aspiration as a starter block but
that's what we want to be involved in
and that's what i want to be aligned
with and if i if
through marketing my fund and aspiration
other things like that we can help those
businesses grow
that that's kind of the key for me i
love it so for people who are
learning about you for the first time
and want to dive deeper into your world
where do you want them to go next
um agopartners.com or check out
aspiration
um open a bank account why not right
it'll change your life
get into the neo banking i love it yeah
yeah alex man thank you for the time the
energy the love
um joining me from from your home uh
you know different country appreciate
all the wisdom and the nuggets and
super pumped for everything you're
building and uh i learned a lot today
too appreciate you
all right thanks evan all right much
love if you want to change your life for
the next 30 days for free
check the link right here below me or if
you want to see the one-on-one i did
with tony robbins check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy them
continue to believe and i'll see you
there